in this video i will explain to you
everything we know about rocks why he
might still be alive as well as a crazy
theory by the best japanese one-piece
youtuber uderon on what really happened
at god valley at the end as you've
probably figured out by now i'm a
gigantic fan of all the legendary
characters in one piece we know close to
nothing about dragon shanks emu and
recently oda has added to that
specialist by introducing us to the most
dangerous pirate crew of the century rox
and their captain rox d sebek a man so
dangerous the government erased all
memory of him
[Music]
i remember i was so shocked when i read
that chapter that i spilled my coffee on
my master thesis but now i'm a youtuber
so i guess it all worked out in the end
also yeah i know i'm failing at pulling
off the khabib beard i'm aware what
makes rocks so incredibly fascinating to
me is that we know for a fact that he
was close to being the most powerful
person in the story the guys i mentioned
earlier emu shanks and dragon could be
very powerful but they also have a lot
of political power that makes them
important as well rox on the other hand
had three out of the five yonko we've
met so far under him and is the role
model for a fourth
big
[Music]
it took both roger and garp the pirate
king and the hero of the marines teaming
up in order to take him down if you want
me to be excited about your character
you know what you have to do
that yeah just just exactly that good
job
hi my name is manu i always thought
geology was kind of boring but look here
i am excited to talk about rocks
who knew so what do we actually know
about this man rox recruited his
powerful and violet crew of violent not
violent although anyways he recruited
them on the island beehive that is now
blackbeard's center of operation we know
that he wanted to rule the world and
that he was defeated during the
mysterious god valley incident 40 years
ago after which the government attempted
to erase him hand the island completely
from history now the problem i have with
this is that we get this information
from sengoku who is not as bad as a
kainu but i still think might just be a
teeny tiny bit biased in this regard i
mean all pirates are evil in the eyes of
the government especially the ones who
are a threat to them something i
discussed in my video on bounties so
while senguku probably tells at least
some of the truth here some of it is
probably a big pile of poop to me garb
is usually the best marine source for
information just like luffy he doesn't
lie but just shares confidential
information left and right
monkeys
however garb hates talking about this
incident one of the reasons might very
well be that he worked together with a
pirate here but then again it's only one
of the reasons garp clearly didn't like
what happened on that island with the
celestial dragons he's a man that
obviously believes in the good of the
marines but despises the world nobles
even though he saved them on that day
together with roger
and by the way it's also interesting to
think about that roger decided to see
glove tail right after this incident
happens hell i would bet my grandma that
something happened on god valley that
would have been devastating for the
world government had it come to light
something i will discuss in the uteron
theory
hello hello
uh my mom says hi
and sorry for my bad manners
sorry grandma point is for all we know
rocks might well have been a morally way
more complicated and grey character than
we think
he could well have had a noble ideal to
free the world or expose the government
which would explain why the likes of big
mom or whitebeard were part of his crew
as well who also believe in a better
world for everyone so who knows maybe
rox actually had a good dream but tried
to reach it through the wrong means
it's also quite possible that rox
actually knew quite a lot about the true
history as well since sengoku mentions
this
just like rayleigh tells luffy that they
might come to a different conclusion
than they did when reaching love tale
maybe rox also came to a different
conclusion himself one thing i actually
really wanted to talk about is beehive
island which is a pretty cute name for
what it actually is and how fitting
because this video is sponsored by
ninjala ninjala is a free to play
bubblegum brawler exclusively on
nintendo switch and since it's free to
play you actually don't require
subscription for nintendo switch online
to play it ninjala is kicking off its
eighth season by collaborating with the
samurai anime series ruroni kenshin the
event begins on december 15th and runs
through january 12th this collab
features weapons and modes stickers a
gun bottle gamutsusemi a commemorative
in-game t-shirt and four exclusive
costumes you can equip to your in-game
avatar inspired by kenchin himura hajime
saito aoshi shinomori and makoto
season 8 will also feature the battle
frequency bonus which will reward you
with items featured in the collaboration
based on the number of matches they win
as well as an in-game tournament called
the ruroni kenshin cup on january 8th if
you want to check it out link is in the
description below this island that was
rox's home base is also known as the
pirate island and funnily enough during
the davey backfight arc robin explains
that the game originated on that very
same islands now i have to admit that
the davey back fight on long ring long
long island long is the only part of the
entire one piece saga that i find
intolerable to watch foxy is annoying
the entire thing is just weird and it's
just too goddamn long no pun intended
that being said even though foxy's games
are terrible we know that this event is
a quite legitimate thing in the pirate
[Music]
people do take this pretty seriously and
can you imagine someone like doflamingo
or kaido playing donut race this is a
game that allows pirates to take crew
members from the opponent and shame them
i would bet i'm sure that the davey back
fight is a much more dark and serious
event usually and the fact that it
originated on beehive island might tell
us that rox was only able to forge such
a crew of monsters by playing this very
game whether that is true or not i
really hope we get to see some serious
payoff for this arc in some way or form
in the future because otherwise
why
[Applause]
before we get to euron and his theory i
have one more thing i found really
interesting to think about what if the
entire story about god valley was false
and rox actually won that day he then
could have crowned himself king of the
world which would of course have meant
the end for rox as a crew he then could
have simply erased all the evidence of
that place and the events there
including his old name calling himself
imu from there on out hell that would
also explain why roger fought for the
nobles and why garb doesn't like talking
about it now do i believe this theory
not really i still prefer the one from
this video right here but it's an
intriguing thought nonetheless by the
way should rox actually still be alive
i've seen some people who say that he
resembles blackbeard or dragon and that
they might be related in some sense but
the first person i thought of when i saw
his silhouette here was this dude right
here not very likely i give you that but
he does look the most like it okay time
for euron's theory on the god valley
incident and a quick challenge for you
go subscribe if you're brave enough and
of course this wouldn't be a ud on
theory without a good old wordplay it's
only one this time though promise and
it's more of an observation anyway than
being part of the theory the word play
for the legendary chapter 957 where
rocks and the god valley incidents are
revealed is kyu gochi which in japanese
means the rallying place where people
come together this fits because of the
marines gathering because of beehive
where rox gathered his crew but
especially for god valley were all the
yonko before blackbeard roger the
marines and the world nobles came
together okay
ally they're actually two word plays the
second one is rock's name itself rokusu
694.
now chapter 694 is titled the most
dangerous man the cover page features
karibu
and is the climax of the punk hazard arc
that ends with the appearance of
doflamingo a former celestial dragon
[Music]
now as you know from my past videos with
yuron oda likes to write his story
according to the principle two sides of
the same coin as in many of the story
elements have a counterpart that is
similar but a bit different if you want
to know more about this in detail i
strongly suggest you check out those
videos afterwards the point here is that
punk hazard seems to be the mirroring
part to god valley which would mean that
the title also refers to rox diesel back
so how could these two islands be
similar well first of all in both cases
we have 2ds going hands luffy and law
versus roger and garp luffy and law save
the dragon momonosuke and the other
slave kids while roger and garp save the
celestial dragons and their slaves both
islands god valley and punk hazard have
been turned into a secret island by the
world governments
just
however since punk hazard still exists
so might god valley now of course the
most interesting part about punk hazard
except the major battle between aokiji
and akainu there was caesar's secret lab
in which he was producing the chemical
for the fake smile devil fruits so if we
mirror this and project this onto god
valley instead of fake devil fruits we
have fake fruits of the gods god valley
and this of course reminds us
immediately of the forbidden fruit in
garden eden the taboo the taboo that
rocks knew about now in japanese god ali
is actually pronounced as gotobare and
body in japanese means actually to be
exposed so not only is it the valley of
the gods but the islands where the
secret of the gods was exposed and
drake's father who found the incredibly
important openomi is called bareuzu in
japanese
could the opie opinomi be the fruit that
was artificially created on god valley
to give the celestial dragons their
immortality we already talked about in
detail why they could be immortal though
people me the fruit doflamingo the man
with the giant complex because he was
pushed out of heaven wanted to have no
matter what to have the immortality
surgery performed on him as well
[Music]
so could the celestial dragons have used
this island to force slaves to perform
that surgery on them and rox was
basically trying to get his hands on the
fruits or maybe something else but
possibly chapter 694 tells us even more
[Music]
what if the celestial dragons that were
defended by garb and roger was actually
the donkey koat family the same family
that later then decided to leave marijua
and become quote unquote good the only
other example of a good ten rubido we
know is none other than don quijote
myosguard who got saved by the goldfish
mermaid queen otohime all of them were
saved and got their humanity back one by
gold roger and the other by goldfish
otahime so it might very well be that
god valley had its name because it was
the place where gods were made if you
haven't seen the other two theories i
made with yuri on you just have to check
them out right here on my face